amis téléspectateurs bonsoir et merci à
celles et ceux qui nous rejoignent sur
LCP ce mois-ci maman j'ai arrêté l'avion
s'intéresse à un sujet qui nous concerne
tous l'eau celle que nous buvons celle
que nous utilisons celle aussi que nous
gaspillons avec le changement climatique
l'eau est devenu un enjeu stratégique et
même politique car l'eau ne coule plus
de source elle se fait même de plus en
plus rare canicule sécheresse hivernale
Riviera sec et nappe phréatique au plus
bas l'eau est le nouvel or bleu que tout
le monde s'arrache parfois violemment
car si l'eau est un bien commun tout le
monde n'est pas logé à la même enseigne
et des derniers 2000 communes ont été
privées d'eau potable en France et le
scénario pourrait bien se répéter l'été
prochain empire au fait maman j'ai
arrêté la viole
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la sécheresse dans l'Hexagone pose
évidemment la question du juste partage
de l'eau de sa gouvernance de son
stockage aussi et questionne par la
force des choses nos modèles de
production particulièrement ce gourmand
en haut comment continuer à produire
dans une France à sec quels sont les
principaux leviers de sobriété quelle
filière soutenir en priorité et quel
changement opéré comment s'adapter enfin
à cette état de sécheresse sportive pour
durer pour en débattre le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires Christophe bécheux
bonsoir bonsoir l'hydro climatologue et
directrice de recherche au CNRS Florence
abeth François bonsoir et le chercheur
politologue et membre du GIEC François
bonsoir à tous les trois et merci de
venir participer à l'effort de guerre
avant de vous donner la parole un état
des lieux en images mais quelques
chiffres d'abord avec notre scientifique
maison Raphaël Itier alors l'utilisation
domestique de l'eau d'abord qui
représente un quart de la consommation
totale en France c'est 148 litres par
personne et par jour le plus gros poste
en matière d'eau de l'agriculture qui
avale 57% de l'eau le souci c'est qu'à
cause du réchauffement climatique les
ressources nationales ont diminué de 14%
environ depuis la fin des années 90 avec
une disparité géographique évidemment et
une région Sud-Ouest qui est
particulièrement concernée alors on leur
a compris l'eau nous est désormais
compté en France qu'ailleurs on cherche
des solutions pour préserver cette
ressource hydrique et la répartir au
mieux selon les besoins présentés comme
la solution pour continuer à irriguer
entendre sécheresse les bassines d'eau
se multiplient un peu partout dans
l'Hexagone et avec elle les points de
tension comme à Sainte Soline dans les
Deux-Sèvres ou pro et antibacines
s'affrontent violemment en jeu 16
réserves de substitutions en cours de
chantier le tout oppose est un reportage
d'Alexis breton et Jaguar l'a dit je
vous laisse regarder et on en parle
juste après
c'est le début du printemps nous sommes
avec le batelier Julien Legay près de
Saint-Hilaire-la-Palud à 40 km de La
Rochelle et de la côte atlantique
et il s'apprête à pigouiller
[Musique]
et l'instrument que j'utilise c'est une
pigouille c'est facile
il y a une espèce de double pique et qui
permet de prendre appui dans le fond
sans déraper quand c'est sur du dur sans
trop s'enfoncer quand c'est sûr du mou
Julien navigue au coeur des cent mille
hectares du Marais Poitevin la deuxième
plus vaste zone humide de France après
la Camargue
malgré la beauté et la sérénité alentour
Julien est inquiet
depuis 50 mètres que je pigouille j'ai
pas vu un brochet j'ai pas vu un gardon
il y a rien rien de rien
là il y a pas un herbier
l'eau est morte
l'essentiel des produits chimiques qui
se déversent dans ce marais poitevin là
qu'elles font de la cuvette c'est
essentiellement en provenance des de
toutes les terres agricoles alentours et
il y a plus de 200 molécules de
pesticides différentes qui ont été
recensés dans le marais poitevin
oiseau grenouille et autres insectes
disparaissent et ce n'est peut-être pas
le pire l'eau déserte ces zones
qu'on voit là c'est le niveau
qui est censé être maintenu en été c'est
le niveau que l'État avec les syndicats
de marée mouillés qui sont les syndicats
de propriétaires s'engagent à maintenir
et là on est début avril et on est déjà
quasiment 10 cm en dessous c'est eau qui
est parti il est pas dit qu'il y a une
nouvelle pluie qui viennent le remplir
l'épisode de 32 jours sans pluie fin
janvier et la très forte sécheresse de
l'été dernier nogur rien de bon pour ce
militant écologiste la raréfaction de
l'eau devient le problème numéro 1 et
surtout ce qui en est la cause selon lui
l'accaparement de cette ressource par
l'industrie agricole
comme un symbole il nous dévoile une
autre menace le méthane présent dans le
sous-sol né de la décomposition des
feuilles dans la vase
de l'eau jaillit le feu
si ces zones humides s'assèchent ce puis
s'engage à effet de serre sera libéré
dans l'atmosphère voilà aussi pourquoi
il faut tout faire pour protéger l'eau
c'est un élément vital
dont on dépend tous et qui actuellement
est pas respecté et qui est mis en péril
pour quelques-uns et de ça ça génère une
forme de feu de colère
une colère qui se dirige aujourd'hui
contre les méga bassines c'est retenu
d'eau gigantesques construites pour
alimenter certaines exploitations
agricoles
ici à 2025 16 réservoirs d'eau géants
vont voir le jour dans la région du
Marais Poitevin des réserves
artificielles capables de stocker à
l'air libre plus de 5 millions de mètres
cubes d'eau le précieux liquide sera
puisé directement dans la nappe
phréatique qui alimente les villes les
villages de la région en eau potable
c'est le plus grand de ces futurs lacs
artificielles qui cristallise toutes les
oppositions
situées sur la commune de Sainte-Souline
il s'étendra sur plus de 10 hectares
lieu de manifestation et d'affrontement
depuis plus d'un an
méga bassine ou réserve de substitution
symbole de l'agrobusiness ou réponse à
la sécheresse deux visions s'opposent
d'un côté Thierry Boudot l'un des
porteurs du projet bassines de l'autre
l'hydrologue Emma Aziza
si on n'a pas assez retenues d'eau on
est à terme contraint de supprimer
l'irrigation sur ce même territoire et
donc on perd toute la diversité agricole
dont on a besoin ce qui va se passer
avec ses bassines c'est que si on décide
de construire le nombre de bassines
qu'on a envisagé en France on va se
retrouver avec encore plus de surface
qui vivront des stress hydriques plus
importants et des nappes qui vont se
tarir
dans la campagne niortaise
non loin du Marais Poitevin vous avez
combien de portes comme ça j'en ai trois
nous avons rendez-vous dans un camp
retranché
c'est pas facile de rentrer ici et pour
cause devenant l'enjeu de beaucoup de
contestations et de beaucoup
d'interrogations il nous a fallu
protéger ce site tel un fort en plein
désert Philippe Maufrais est le maire de
mauzé-sur-lignon une commune de 3000
âmes c'est la dernière qui abrite un
trésor qu'il faut absolument protéger
de l'or bleu en grande quantité
on est toujours à bossé sur le mignon et
non pas à mauzé-sur-mer non non pas du
tout et vous avez en face de vous mais
bien l'étendue que représente 241
000 mètres cubes sur cette hectar 5 de
surface au sol
voilà ce que appelle réserve de
substitution
construite en hauteur à base de sable et
de béton son fonds et recouvert d'une
bâche en PVC afin de conserver l'eau
issue de la nappe phréatique une eau qui
va permettre d'irréguler l'été prochain
5 exploitations voisines grâce à des
kilomètres de tuyaux enterrés sur le
mignon je parle l'élevage je perds la
culture je n'ai plus rien j'ai quelques
sociétés qui sont là bien évidemment
dans la périphérie de moset mais
néanmoins le plus important pour moi
c'est cette économie lié intimement à
l'agriculture le dernier le dernier été
on a vu quand même l'extrême chaleur que
nous avons eu donc il faut maintenant
commencer à imaginer l'avenir et faire
des réserves d'eau pour cela Monsieur le
Maire et les agriculteurs du coin n'ont
pas hésité à dépenser beaucoup d'argent
notamment celui de l'État cette réserve
a coûté 2 millions et demi d'euros dont
70% de subventions publiques qui a payé
pour les barbelés et autres caméras
anti-intrusion
[Musique]
on ne le saura pas une chose est sûre le
maire est convaincu du bien-fondé du
projet
l'eau par principe quand elle est là
c'est quand elle est en excès elle est
en excès et bon la réserve pour le
moment difficile et j'ai bien dit
lorsque les épisodes plus vieux sont
nombreux et qui nous apportent cette
quantité d'eau on la met de côté quand
vous avez un peu trop d'argent que vous
touchez un petit héritage vous faites
bien des placements bah nous on fait
pareil en aucun cas on peut dire que
elle est piocher de l'eau dans une nappe
phréatique c'est une solution et encore
plus avec des nouvelles conditions qui
arrivent en France où on a même plus
depuis l'hiver en fait la nappe
phréatique c'est le moyen facile de
pouvoir produire toujours plus aller
chercher toujours plus d'eau quitte à ce
qu'on la pie complètement cette nappe
quitte à ce qu'on l'a détruise
l'adversité du changement climatique ont
la mesure elle va être telle qu'il faut
utiliser tous les leviers dont on a
notre disposition
faut planter des haies faire des retenus
d'eau collectives mais avoir un partage
de l'eau public c'est indispensable le
partage c'est justement une partie du
problème l'eau des bassines bien public
ne va bénéficier directement qu'un tout
petit nombre d'agriculteurs une petite
partie des exploitants irrigants de la
coopérative de l'eau des Deux-Sèvres
assiste-t-on alors à une privatisation
d'une ressource vitale
réponse à quelques kilomètres de la
réserve de mosée sur le mignon François
petorin prépare son chant pour les
futurs semis il fait partie de ceux qui
militent pour la construction des
bassines c'est vraiment indispensable on
a des sols très superficiels les
cultures ont besoin d'eau que ce soit au
printemps ou en été et après les
blétants aussi par moment au mois de mai
juin en fonction de la climato ils ont
besoin d'eau pour remplir pour remplir
le grain donc oui c'est vital pour le
territoire pour l'agriculture
François cultive principalement des
céréales sur une exploitation de 200
hectares l'année prochaine il sera
raccordé à une bassine encore en
construction
alors aujourd'hui le projet au total sur
les 16 réserves qui seront prévues c'est
220 exploitations mais ça représente 450
agriculteurs au total sur l'ensemble du
territoire de sainte Soline à osé sur le
mignon ou à proximité on a un volume
attribué par l'État donc l'eau nous
appartient pas n'appartient à personne
donc il y a pas de privatisation ou
d'acaparent comme il peut être dit on
peut affirmer que ce n'est pas une une
privatisation de l'eau mais il n'y a pas
d'autres termes à partir du moment où
vous prenez de l'eau et que vous la
conservez pour vos usages au détriment
des autres ça s'appelle une
privatisation de l'eau le problème c'est
qu'on va de plus en plus être face à des
économies qui vont se confronter les
unes avec les autres le milieu
énergétique qui a besoin de quantité
d'eau nos robinets ont besoin d'eau
notre humanité a besoin d'eau donc on
voit à quel point et bien il va falloir
faire des choix et c'est vraiment tout
l'enjeu qu'on a actuellement et c'est
ces frictions qu'on voit arriver on
n'est pas dans un projet où c'est un
club fermé
d'agriculteurs qui avait des droits
historiques qui peuvent irriguer demain
c'est exactement l'inverse en fait c'est
le territoire qui décide tous les ans
d'une répartition de l'eau et il faut
que l'accès à l'eau pour tous les
agriculteurs qui le demandent soit le
même il faut pas de distance
ce qu'il oublie de nous dire c'est que
seul 6% des agriculteurs seraient
raccordés en l'état actuel du projet les
autres devront compter sur des nappes
suffisamment chargé l'été pour pouvoir
irriguer comment c'est fait la
répartition les gros exploitants les
adeptes de l'agriculture productiviste
sont-ils favorisés avant c'est Rémi le
rando est un petit maraîcher
qui cultive des légumes bio sur trois
hectares
les patates primeur avant d'avoir la
semaine prochaine
sur cette aire il fait très attention à
sa consommation en eau
donc le goutte à goutte c'est un système
tout simple c'est de l'eau à basse
pression qui va passer dedans le tuyau
est perforé en fait tous les 20 cm là
donc là on a une perte de l'eau qui est
très très faible en fait pour un rendu
super c'est du 90% utilisable par la
plante comme François Rémy a lui aussi
membre de la coopérative de l'eau et
finance une petite partie des travaux
débats mais contrairement à son collègue
céréalier le maraîcher a vu sa demande
de raccordement
ignorée alors moi j'avais demandé en
2019 à un raccordement à un projet de
bassine sur une autre commune et ma
lettre est restée sans réponse pendant
deux ans il faut savoir que vu mon
faible volume ça coûterait trop cher et
je le comprends à la collectivité donc à
la Coop de l'eau ça leur coûterait trop
cher de me raccorder ce serait pas
rentable
pas de raccordement et une grande peur
[Musique]
la ressource en eau de mon exploitation
donc c'est un puit il est très peu
profond on voit l'eau là
son puits plonge dans la même nappe
phréatique que la plus célèbre des
mégabassines
c'est les mêmes c'est les mêmes sources
moi ma crainte c'est que mon puits soit
sec
et ça j'avais demandé des garanties et
j'en ai pas parce que moi si j'ai plus
d'eau je peux plus irriguer j'ai plus de
légumes j'ai plus d'exploitation un
problème que n'auront pas les plus gros
producteurs ceux qui font pousser du blé
du maïs du colza et de la betterave à
coup de pesticides et de centaines de
milliers de mètres cubes d'eau
[Musique]
un système agroalimentaire
intensif qui a besoin de beaucoup d'eau
face à des ruraux qui sont aussi des
maraîchers locaux et je crois que sainte
Soline quelque part est à l'image de ces
modèles qui se confrontent
souvenez-vous c'était le 25 mars dernier
le gigantesque rassemblement non
autorisé contre la non moins gigantesque
construction de sainte Soline
des milliers de manifestants convergent
vers la méga bassine de la discorde
[Applaudissements]
parmi eux l'amoureux du Marais Poitevin
le porte-parole du collectif antibacine
Julien Legay
[Musique]
cinquantaine 60 tracteurs qui sont là
rien que ça c'est une image très forte
ça veut dire que c'est bien les paysans
et le peuple contre la groindustrie non
c'est fini système là place à la vie
[Musique]
sous contrôle judiciaire pour avoir
notamment organisé des manifestations
sans autorisation il a l'interdiction de
se rendre sur la commune de
Sainte-Souline il restera en arrière
la bassine un simple trou pour le moment
est protégé par des centaines de
gendarmes
[Musique]
la bataille de sainte Soline de Caen
face à face pour deux visions
irréconciliables un modèle productif qui
a fait ses preuves et qui assure la
fameuse souveraineté alimentaire du pays
pour les uns pour les autres un modèle
industriel qui refuse toute idée de
changement et de sobriété et qui
entraîne la France vers la catastrophe
la guerre de l'homme a tout l'air
d'avoir commencé Christophe Béchu non
en tout cas on a une crispation
particulièrement forte dans un endroit
très spécial à beaucoup d'égards
cibler dans un reportage un lieu qui a
fait la une de l'actualité c'est
évidemment logique pour informer tout le
monde mais on peut pas résumer ni ce que
serait la stratégie de l'eau à l'échelle
du pays à ce qui se passe dans un
département ni résumé ce qui serait le
modèle souhaitable à quelques échanges
qui ont eu lieu je veux dire les choses
de la manière la plus claire qui soit il
n'y a aucune alternative à la sobriété
on aura moins d'eau se dire qu'on va
trouver des méthodes pour continuer à
faire comme si on pouvait en avoir
autant ça n'est pas possible et il n'y a
pas de meilleur retenu que les nappes
phréatiques pas des vapo transpiration
une capacité à stocker l'eau dans de
bonnes conditions une fois que j'ai dit
ça et que j'ai posé ces principes qui
sont réellement la base de toute la
réflexion qu'on doit être capable de
conduire
on est sur un bout de territoire de
France avec ces particularités avec un
accord entre la gauche qui gère la
région la droite qui gère le département
alors c'est basines sont très
controversés ailleurs pas juste dans le
département
où on en discute de manière particulière
on exacerbe entre guillemets les
tensions contenu leur taille contenu de
leur dimension qui sont effectivement
hors norme par rapport à ce qui se passe
ailleurs et contenu à La Clusaz enfin un
peu partout en Haute-Savoie il y a deux
types de retenue il y a celle qui
prennent de l'eau de pluie et qui sont
souvent moins controversées parce qu'on
comprend le phénomène qui consiste à
alors on va en parler avec Laurence je
dis pas que c'est toujours le meilleur
système et le système là qui interroge
l'opinion publique parce que on tombe
dans une nappe qui est censée justement
permettre de préserver les choses pour
aller le mettre dans une bassine qui est
à l'air libre le point de rencontre
entre les deux c'est qu'on est sur un
sous-sol karstique c'est-à-dire fuyant
qui ne retient pas l'eau ce qui explique
qu'on est eu des études favorables à
cette réalisation et qu'on est des
décisions de justice y compris au mois
d'avril dernier favorable à ce projet
parce qu'on a ces caractéristiques très
particulières enfin malgré le caractère
tout à fait bucolique du reportage je
tiens quand même juste à rappeler en 15
secondes
que si la manifestation a été interdite
c'est pas parce que le débat est
impossible c'est parce qu'au moins
d'octobre plus de 60 gendarmes ont été
blessés à l'occasion d'une première
manifestation de ce type et que au
milieu de ceux qui légitimement peuvent
choisir ou considérer qu'il faut aller
vers une autre type d'agriculture ou de
solution on a des gens qui sont venus
spécifiquement pour blesser des
gendarmes la manifestation a été
interdite contenue des craintes et
malheureusement ces craintes elles ont
été avérées avec à nouveau des
affrontements qui n'ont rien d'une
balade en forêt France German vous êtes
pénétologue vous êtes d'accord avec
Christophe Béchu les les antibacines
sont venus pour pour casser du gendarme
non je pense que c'est pas spécialement
les antibacis c'est que aujourd'hui dans
toutes les manifestations quel que soit
le motif que ce soit les bacilles la
réforme des retraites etc vous avez des
gens qui effectivement viennent pour
frapper des gendarmes des policiers et
si t'es acceptables et on est dans une
logique de surenchère dans le maintien
de l'ordre qui fait qu'aujourd'hui il y
a des gens qui se retrouvent à avoir
peur de manifester ce qui pas possible
dans une démocratie moderne le droit de
manifester est un droit fondamental et
j'aurais juste comprendre vous les juger
pertinentes ces à l'heure de la hausse
des températures en France ce sont des
chiffres que vous avez annoncé plus 2 et
demi degrés en 2030 plus 3 degrés en
2050 + 4 degrés en moyenne en 2100 pour
que l'on comprenne bien est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est méga bassines sont
pertinentes à l'aune de la hausse de sa
température en fait c'est la vraie
question le sujet c'est qu'elles ont été
validées dans un contexte qui était des
modèles les seuls aujourd'hui dont on
dispose qui consiste à projeter ce que
sera la ressource disponible contenue
d'une augmentation des températures
basées sur une un plus de degré dans le
plan que nous avons présenté
même pas nous allons actualiser d'ici la
fin de l'année les prévisions pour
justement intégrer la perspective non
pas d'une France qui se réchauffe de 2
degrés mais qui se réchauffe avec des
températures qui peuvent attendre 4
degrés ce que j'ai eu l'occasion de dire
c'est-à-dire modifier les modèles et les
références qui permettent au BRGM de
faire ses projections un des axes de
critique c'est de dire on n'a pas été ce
qui n'a pas été le cas pour ces méga
bassines ça a été sur la base des
prévisions de 2000 de 2000 2011
sans prendre en compte le réchauffement
climatique si prenons encore
le bureau de recherche géologique est
minière ne l'a pas pris c'est lui qui le
dit non il dit on s'est basé sur les
chiffres de 2006 à 2011 le nouveau
modèle qui prend en compte ces 4 degrés
il est en train d'être établi il sera
disponible à la fin de l'année on peut
pas reprocher une étude avec le Bergen
n'a été fait dans le contexte de
sensoline enfin des bassines avec le
changement climatique ça a été fait avec
le changement climatique non j'étais à
1,5°
sincèrement je ne peux pas vous laisser
dire ça parce qu'encore une fois si vous
reprenez les études ont été faites sur
la base des données qui datent de 2006 à
2011 et nous sommes en train en ce
moment de doter le BRGM en fin d'année
de ce nouveau modèle qui s'appelle
raexplorer qui permet de faire des
projections avec des températures plus
élevées alors aussi impliquées dans ce
projet donc je connais assez bien
c'est un des loupés de cette
concertation qui est malgré tout très
bien venu de la COP 79 d'avoir réussi à
rassembler tous les agriculteurs d'un
territoire pour discuter du partage de
l'eau ça c'était super pour quand même
régler un problème qui était en fait
antérieur bien antérieure à ça une sûr
irrigation finalement dans les années 90
qui ont vraiment mis en péril la
ressource en eau de la région avec des
étiages très très marqués et c'est
finalement pour résoudre un problème
ancien que ces bassines ont été pensées
mais elles ont été pensées sans le
changement climatique justement et c'est
là tout à fait le risque de la
maladaptation parce que comme vous le
savez un des problèmes pour s'adapter au
changement climatique c'est le poids de
l'héritage c'est le fait que on dispose
d'outils un moment qui finalement
imposent des stratégies d'un pour
finalement rentabiliser tout ça et
aujourd'hui investir de nouveau
renforcer encore cette dépendance à une
irrigation quand même assez intensive
c'est ça la question qui se pose la
question qui se pose aussi c'est qu'il y
a un consensus scientifique autour de
ses bassines et de ses réserves d'eau
pour dire que c'est tout sauf une
solution en quoi sont-elles néfastes
parce qu'elles appauvrissent les sols
elles aggravent la sécheresse ce qui se
passe c'est que Sébastien enfin tout
toutes ces retenues qui sont dédiées
uniquement à l'irrigation elles vise
finalement à permettre une irrigation
qui est souvent relativement coûteuse
donc on demande souvent des rendements
importants elles sont pas là pour
sécuriser comme on entend parfois dire
puisque en fait sécuriser ça veut dire
j'ai de l'eau mais je l'utilise que
quand j'en ai besoin c'est à dire
rarement la plupart du temps je ne
l'utilise pas là on n'est pas du tout
dans ce contexte là on va optimiser une
ressource aujourd'hui dans un temps
présent ça veut dire que dès qu'il y
aura une sécheresse dès qu'il y aura un
manque d'eau et bien j'aurais quand même
tout consommé et pour autant je serai
peut-être
incapable de produire par exemple l'été
dernier il y a eu de l'irrigation du
maïs qui a été fait dans le Sud-Ouest et
pourtant pas de production pourquoi
parce qu'il y a eu des échaudages déjà
en temps présent mais demain c'est
encore plus clivant et finalement
pourquoi on pense que c'est pas
forcément la bonne solution non pas pour
dire que
ce soit pas partie de la solution mais
il faut absolument pas baser toute la
solution ce que vous dites exactement ce
que je dis mais les conditions
climatiques de demain imposeront
malheureusement sans doute que pour
produire un peu de rendement il va
falloir que peut-être plus de gens aient
accès à l'eau et ça repose donc tout à
fait le partage de l'eau sur quoi l'état
énorme parce que c'est la question avec
les températures du type de culture bien
sûr nous faisons c'est la question des
sols c'est effectivement y compris la
question des temporalités parce qu'il
nous arrive d'avoir des productions
l'hiver qui sont plus consommatrices en
eau mais on n'a pas de problème d'eau
l'hiver ou l'automne
plus je le dis à des cinq contenus de
l'hiver qu'on a vécu et du fait qu'on
repose aujourd'hui sur des certitudes
donc quand je dis que la commande a été
passée des trajectoires qui nous
permettent d'intégrer un impact d'un
réchauffement climatique pas un petit
comme celui qu'on anticipait il y a 20
ou 30 ans mais la réalité de ce que
aujourd'hui toutes les études
scientifiques sont en train de dire
c'est qu'on ne fera pas l'économie quand
ce nouveau modèle de projection sera
disponible à la fin de l'année de
refaire tourner une partie des
hypothèses sur lesquelles peuvent
figurer des projets sur la base de ces
nouvelles projections
pour se rendre compte que le modèle est
déjà caduque y compris dans cette région
là je suis étiée ça n'est pas à vous que
je vais expliquer que j'ai beaucoup
d'humilité devant les scientifiques
devant les experts sur un certain nombre
de domaines et si nous faisons
travailler le BRGM mais pas seulement
l'inrae d'autres acteurs Météo France
c'est parce que il y a des choses qu'on
sait et puis il y a une part d'humilité
sur laquelle il faut être capable de
croiser les connaissances et j'attends
la conclusion de tous ces experts pour
avoir véritablement un modèle de faire
tourner
à la décision dans un contexte où je
redis ce que j'ai dit à l'origine
nous aurons moins d'eau disponible
entièrement mais entre 10 et 40% en
fonction des secteurs sur lesquels on se
trouve la sobriété et la seule option
dont on dispose à moyen terme et les
nappes sont notre urgence absolue et
donc même si ça peut paraître décalé la
lutte contre l'artificialisation et
l'étalement urbain la perméabilisation
des sols de nos villes c'est aussi
important que les discussions qu'on a
sur les parties rurales sur la sur le
type de culture qu'on aura parce que
tout est lié on va parler de ce brité la
gestion de l'eau on leur a compris est
un enjeu majeur en se souvient tous peu
auproux de nos cours de biologie à
l'école consacrée au cycle de l'eau un
cycle que l'agriculture par ses
pratiques intensives perturbent mais
Rafa Litier il n'y a pas que l'eau bleue
qui est impactée il y a aussi l'eau
verte bref on a besoin que vous nous
rafraîchissiez la mémoire ça tombe bien
c'est l'heure du climatoscope et c'est à
vous
je vais revenir d'abord sur le cycle
général de l'eau on sait où on se
souvient à peu près tout ce que des
océans injectent de grandes quantités de
l'atmosphère que la masse d'air humide
en fait monte c'est refroidit et donc
échec des petites molécules d'eau qui
deviennent des gouttes et qui vont finir
par retomber sur les sur les reliefs et
donner lieu à un ruissellement qui donne
donc les ruisseaux les rivières et donc
les fleuves puis qui retournent dans
l'océan maintenant quand on voit couler
la rivière en fond de son jardin ou la
scène sous le pont Mirabeau on a
l'impression que tout va bien et
pourtant ça n'est pas le cas non ce
n'est pas le cas c'est au moins une
illusion puisque quand on ne regarde que
le niveau des lacs est des rivières on
ne fait pas attention à ce qu'on appelle
le cycle de l'eau verte c'est-à-dire que
toute l'eau qui tombe ne retourne pas
directement dans les dans les océans
quand il pleut l'eau imprime les sols
une partie va s'infiltrer jusque dans
les nappes phréatiques on en a parlé
tout à l'heure et l'autre partie est
absorbée au passage par les plantes qui
par les racines vont réinjecter l'eau
dans les parties aériennes qui elle-même
transpire des gros volumes d'eau et qui
vont participer aux précipitations et
donc c'est ça le cycle le cycle de l'eau
verte et on vient de se rendre compte
l'année dernière notamment à travers une
grosse publication que ce cycle ne va
pas très très bien les scientifiques oui
ne va pas bien disons-le les
scientifiques ont été évalués l'humidité
des sols dans une multitude de pays il
constate que sur un cinquième de ces
termes les teneurs en eau sont anormales
par rapport au passé et un niveau
d'anormalité qui est tel que les
scientifiques parlent d'une nouvelle
limite planétaire franchie au même titre
que le réchauffement climatique
l'érosion la biodiversité ou la
pollution chimique or on sait que ce
cycle de l'eau verte est perturbé par
l'artificialisation des sols l'expansion
urbaines la déforestation et
l'agriculture intensive c'est quatre
phénomènes en fait empêchent le sol de
retenir l'humidité ce qui accélère la
ridification liée à la hausse des
températures évidemment ce qui donc
constitue un cercle vicieux et un cercle
vicieux qui n'est pas sans conséquence
j'imagine absolument ça peut aboutir à
la modification de la répartition de
l'eau à l'échelle de continents entiers
et on peut prendre un exemple frappant
la déforestation en Amazonie l'Amazonie
on la voit comme un le poumon vert de la
planète qu'on oublie assez souvent c'est
que c'est aussi une énorme fontaine
d'eau il faut savoir qu'il y a un grand
arbre en Amazonie peut injecter jusqu'à
1000 litres d'eau dans l'atmosphère donc
le bilan est absolument énorme les
volumes d'eau qui circulent dans le dans
l'air sont plus importantes que le débit
du fleuve Amazone qui est pourtant le
plus grand fleuve du monde c'est pour ça
que les scientifiques parlent de
rivières volantes et ces rivières
volantes vont venir arroser la totalité
d'un continent le continent de
l'Amérique du Sud et la vie de millions
de gens dépend de cette eau qui vient
irriguer irriguer leur sol on a donc un
point très important sur le cycle de
l'eau verte qui est en train de basculer
nous disent les scientifiques alors la
question qui se pose en ce moment c'est
le juste partage de cette eau
l'agriculture irriguée représente
seulement
7,3% de la surface agricole utilisée en
France surface
par le fait qu'on serait obligé
d'augmenter nos importations
très concrètement on a des marges
d'amélioration dans l'agriculture qui
sont considérables il y a pas des
aventures possibles sans eau vous avez
rappelé les chiffres moins 10% des
terres qui sont irrigués avec des
systèmes de goutte à gouttes qui sont
économes des pratiques aujourd'hui en
termes de culture où on ne sait même pas
attention aux horaires auxquels on va
irriguer et donc on génère de la
surévaporation l'été passé les
céréaliers irriguait par 30 degrés sous
le cagnard en pleine journée des
cultures c'est aberrant quand on veut
économiser et parler et quand on parle
de sobriété c'est bien pour ça que quand
j'évoquais la question de la nature des
sols et des températures pour être
capable d'aller modifier des
trajectoires d'agriculture c'est aussi
ce qui nous attend ce que je veux vous
dire c'est qu'on a globalement
l'amélioration de ce qui relève de
l'hydraulique agricole ce qui relève des
techniques d'irrigation mais je reviens
à mon sujet sur la sobriété et sur le
fait qu'on a en face de nous des
phénomènes sur lesquels pensaient qu'on
sera plus fort que la nature c'est une
folie le sujet c'est comme on assure
cette transition parce qu'entre les deux
les agriculteurs ils le font pour nous
nourrir pour bien un dispositif ou un
système dans lequel à la fin si c'est
encore une fois pour augmenter nos
importations on améliore ni la situation
de la planète ni la situation hydrique
globale puisque vous savez que le maïs
qui est utilisé pour la minimumation
animale nécessite l'importation de soja
donc on est quand même aussi dans cette
du Brésil vous avez mentionné à la
dernière émission qui était sur
l'alimentation si vous continuez à
dézoomer que vous ajoutez la totalité
vous savez très bien qu'il y a pas
seulement la position française mais les
stratégies qui sont les stratégies
internationales de d'autres pays la
manière dont aujourd'hui on a monté des
accords de libre-échange en considérant
que ça allait permettre à des
populations de sortir de la pauvreté
ailleurs sur la planète donc on peut
simplifier les choses et faire comme si
une décision en France à Paris à
quelques semaines de l'été pouvait tout
bouleverser il faut un peu d'humilité
dans le fait d'être capable ensuite de
relier ces enjeux alors le gouvernement
a débloqué 10 millions d'euros
soit 166 euros par ferme pour le bio
toute filière confondues contre une
enveloppe de 270 millions l'an passé
juste pour la filière port vous
considérez que c'est une répartition
juste quant aujourd'hui nous sommes en
situation de stress hydrique et qu'il
faudrait soutenir avant tout et je parle
sur votre contrôle la gros foresterie et
l'agroécologie
me proposer des chiffres comme ça dans
un contexte je suis très heureux de
parler de polyphonie qui me permettent
de défendre seul un certain nombre de
position ce que je veux dire c'est
peut-être remettre les choses à leur
place typiquement y compris dans le plan
qui vient d'être présenté l'accent que
nous mettons et les crédits les plus
importants ils sont pour la conversion
au bio et pour l'agroécologie c'est 200
millions d'euros annuels indépendamment
des crédits de soutien aux filières qui
étaient déjà existant auparavant
François jammani l'augmentation des
forts contradiction à vouloir s'adapter
à la sécheresse en dispensant et en
exonérant de toute effort le plus gros
consommateur agricole c'est je dirais un
exemple type de ce qu'on appelle la mal
adaptation c'est à dire des solutions
d'adaptation qui soit devant essayer de
résoudre un problème immédiat mais vont
compromettre les capacités d'adaptation
dans le futur donc en gros un emplâtre
sur une jambe de bois et malheureusement
c'est un peu ce qui se passe avec les
mega Bastille on peut comprendre le
point de vue des agriculteurs qui sont
parfois un peu acculés qui disent si je
peux pas irriguer mes cultures ben je
vais devoir faire des boutiques mais ça
risque effectivement de compromettre nos
capacités d'adaptation dans le futur et
ça c'est vraiment un enjeu fondamental
et je crois que en s'accrochant à des
modèles agricoles du passé qui sont très
dépendants de l'irrigation en réalité on
tire une balle dans le pied des
agriculteurs parce que sur le long terme
on garantira pas la pérennité de
l'agriculture ni des revenus décents
pour des agriculteurs qui sont
aujourd'hui en souffrance pour la
plupart et puis l'autre enjeu c'est
évidemment la question du partage de la
ressource et des conflits d'usage c'est
à dire que d'un coup une ressource qu'on
croyait jadis abondante et limitée pour
laquelle on se posait pas vraiment la
question du partage avec des
comportements aberrants parfois en
termes d'irrigation et bien d'un coup
cette ressource devient de plus en plus
limitée et donc on va avoir des conflits
de plus en plus violents comme celui
qu'on a vu à Sainte Soline sur cette
question précisément de l'allocation
d'une ressource de plus en plus rare ça
va être le cas évidemment pour l'eau ça
va être le cas pour les et ça va
évidemment et surtout être le cas pour
la question du carbone qui a le droit
d'utiliser quel budget carbone
aujourd'hui dans un contexte où il va
évidemment falloir réduire drastiquement
notre empreinte carbone vous entendez
non seulement je l'entends mais j'ai
l'impression qu'on a un discours qui est
décoré de ce qui se passe on prend un
exemple dans un coin de France sur
effectivement la base d'un protocole de
2018 je vois qu'il y a plein de choses à
dire et on fait comme si la stratégie
globale était celle d'une Mad adaptation
quelques semaines après qu'on a expliqué
que tout le monde allait doit faire des
efforts qu'on met précis tout le monde
le secteur agricole c'est totalement
faux le ministre votre homologue à
l'agriculture marque Renault a dit que
le la filière agricole n'aurait aucun
effort supplémentaire à faire j'ai donc
je peux vous montrer que dans les propos
qu'il a tenu il a expliqué que la part
qui était dévolue à l'agriculture sera
la même non allez diminuer à l'hectare
vous reprendrez ses propos lors de la
conférence de presque que nous avons
fait conjointement au lendemain de la
présentation du plan haut où il a
expliqué que la part globale pour
l'agriculture
n'allez pas varier en pourcentage mais
que elle allait bien diminuée en
tendance dans le cadre de
ce qui a été dit j'ai compris qu'il y
avait pas d'efforts demandés à
l'agriculture c'était comme ça que ça a
été présenté je trouvais ça maladroit
parce qu'effectivement comme vous le
dites vous l'avez compris comme ça c'est
que c'est maladroit je prends la douche
comme ça ça n'est pas possible d'avoir
globalement une baisse des prélèvements
une baisse de consommation qui consiste
à dire qu'on va rien changer ça n'existe
pas
je peux vous assurer que donc la filière
agricole va faire un effort elle aussi
mais la filière agricole elle n'est ni
aveugle ni sous mais de toute façon vous
savez aujourd'hui les prises de parole
et de façon contraignante mais comment
voulez-vous qu'on fasse autrement ce que
je veux dire c'est que tout le
concrètement la seule non mais le débat
que nous avons c'est entre l'espèce de
pureté scientifique qui consiste à
expliquer qu'il faut tout changer de
matin et le fait de réaliser qu'on est
en face de nous des hommes et des femmes
des investissements une réalité y
compris alimentaire qui nécessite de
concevoir ces transitions vous savez et
donc de regarder le prix de l'action va
être terrible mais
je suis même en train de vous expliquer
que pour la première fois depuis 20 ans
qu'on me donne des précédents tout ce
qui a été fait en matière de gestion de
l'eau en matière de trajectoire de
sobriété depuis 20 ans on est en train
de construire une gouvernance qui n'a
rien à voir avec ce qu'on a fait par le
passé il faut comprendre aussi que c'est
je crois que c'est dans l'intérêt des
agriculteurs
agricoles en tenant compte des impacts
du changement climatique on condamne
littéralement les agriculteurs non
seulement parce qu'ils n'auront plus de
rendement mais surtout parce qu'ils vont
devoir mettre des fils de fer barbeler
autour de leur culture comme on l'a vu
dans le reportage et qu'on va pas faire
de l'agriculture encore retranché enfin
c'est pas possible ni pour les
agriculteurs ni évidemment pour les
opposants un mot sur la qualité de l'eau
vous en parliez tout à l'heure 90% des
cours d'eau et des rivières sont
contaminées aux pesticides un tiers de
l'eau potable en France a été polluée
par un pesticide le saint-jeintin
utiliser depuis 1970 et interdit en 2019
c'est contamination sont massives et
pourtant Emmanuel Macron n'en a pas eu
un mot dans son plan haut comment ça se
fait alors vous avez tout un volet sur
la qualité qui regroupe une dizaine de
mesures et qui
notamment repose sur le fait qu'on mette
en place un plan de gestion sur la
sécurité sanitaire des eaux pour chaque
captage et on va beaucoup plus loin dans
le plan puisqu'on explique que les
préfets prendront des mesures
automatiques de fermeture on a eu au
cours de ces dernières années pour des
questions de dépassement de seuil 4300
captages d'eau fermés en France
exactement et potentiel énorme c'est
énorme mais c'est la hauteur du chiffre
que vous n'avez pas donné c'est que nous
n'avons que 43% de nos masses d'eau au
sens large qui sont considérés comme
étant de bonne qualité alors
qu'auriez-vous envie de répondre
Christophe Béchu à votre homologue Marc
fenault qui veut repousser
l'interdiction de l'herbicide s métola
chlore en France utilisé par les
céréaliers pour lutter contre les
mauvaises herbes mais accusé par
l'agence de sécurité sanitaire de
polluer les nappes phréatiques et
accessoirement qui a été classé en juin
2022 comme cancérogène probable on
marche sur la tête
il n'y a pas de contradiction entre le
fait d'expliquer qu'on a à la fois la
nécessité d'aller interdire et de
souhaiter simplement qu'on le fasse de
manière européenne et sur ce type de
question y compris pour éviter qu'on se
retrouve avec des écarts qui viennent
alimenter y compris une forme
d'hypocrisie parce que si j'interdis un
produit mais qu'il arrive quand même
dans mon assiette parce que je l'emporte
depuis l'Italie l'Allemagne ou la
Belgique je vais faire croire aux
consommateurs qu'on l'a sécurisé alors
que ça n'est pas le cas donc dans ce
domaine ce que la première ministre a eu
l'occasion d'annoncer il y a quelques
semaines c'est que nous allions dans le
cadre du nouveau plan Écophyto prendre
la totalité des produits qui ont
vocation potentiellement être interdits
pour construire les alternatives
aujourd'hui on est dans un espèce de
système qui marche sur la tête on a le
temps d'avoir un avis négatif je suis
heureuse de vouloir dire non mais je
vous le dis exactement
puisque ce truc est interdit on va
maintenant imaginer une alternative et
quand l'alternative sera prête
l'interdiction pourrait être
effectivement
c'est le bio quand même l'enjeu c'est
d'aller modifier le process et c'est de
faire en sorte très concrètement de se
dire ok par rapport à des calendriers
interdiction souhaitable ou probable il
faut maintenant qu'on lance les
programmes de recherche d'alternative
pourquoi ne pas aller directement vers
le bio parce que on sait très bien que
finalement c'est le bio se permet de se
passer de ces pesticides et donc
concerne une bonne qualité de l'eau et
il y avait un objectif il me semble à
une bonne qualité à moins 15% de surface
en bio en France et on en est pas du
tout là et là et le bio est en train
américain c'est pourquoi il y a pas cet
effort alors la transition vers le vers
le bio là aussi je rejoins ce que disait
François Jemen il y a quelques instants
elle est en train d'être adoptée par la
profession on a un effet de recul sur
lequel on est en train de travailler
parce qu'à cause du contexte d'inflation
élevé on a un certain nombre de gens qui
se sont détournés pour des raisons
budgétaires du bio alors qu'en termes de
qualité on voit bien l'impact et
l'intérêt la seule chose que je dis
encore une fois c'est qu'à la fin on est
dans un système d'économie ouvert ou du
bio qui vient du bout du monde il est
moins souhaitable que du local qui vient
de proximité pour avoir dans un passé
récent gérer
à l'échelle d'une collectivité vous
mesurez dans un certain nombre de cas
que vous pouvez pas résumer l'empreinte
écologique d'un produit uniquement au
fait de savoir s'il est bio la question
de sa provenance la question de la
manière dont il a été fait contre il y a
autant que bio ne peuvent pas
s'installer parce qu'ils ont pas accès à
l'eau c'est ce qu'on a vu dans le
reportage
à mettre aussi mais encore une fois ce
que je suis en train je suis ravi d'être
comptable de tout ce qui se passe dans
ce pays depuis 70 ans ou de tout ce qui
ne s'est pas passé ce que je suis en
train de vous expliquer mais vous êtes
en exercice
c'est difficile ce que je suis
simplement en train de vous dire c'est
un grain et le mode transition c'est
pour ça c'est que et vous l'avez très
bien dit pendant
des décennies on a vécu dans une telle
illusion d'abondance que nous n'avons
pas regardé les réformes cohérentes
qu'il fallait qu'on soit capable de
conduire et au moment où on allait faire
on se retrouve avec des tensions des
agriculteurs qu'on bloquer sur un
territoire une route nationale pour
protester contre des interdictions ou
des diminutions d'autorisation de
prélèvement dans les Pyrénées-Orientales
départements dans lesquels on a des
communes qui n'ont pas d'eau potable des
un début du mois d'avril dans lequel
incendie de ce début on voit et c'est
pas le gouvernement qui dit à un moment
on va faire une restriction c'est juste
le constat que en face d'une absence de
ressources on va pas délivrer des
autorisations
vont se répéter en tout cas si le bio
est une solution on en a une à vous
proposer à l'échelle des territoires
comme ici à Grenoble où l'on n'attend
pas d'être au pied du mur pour investir
dans l'habitat de demain se loger en
étant presque autonome en eau et en
énergie c'est possible la preuve par
l'image le monde de demain c'est
maintenant et c'est signé Alexis breton
et Xavier luiset
Grenoble à deux pas du Vercors et au
beau milieu des Alpes françaises 158 240
âmes c'est précis et parmi elles
quelques dizaines d'habitants un peu
particuliers des cobayes qui vivent dans
ces deux immeubles aux allures de
stations spatiale des volontaires pour
la bonne cause pour l'eau comme
Alexandre un enseignant chercheur de 31
ans
sa voisine à la retraite qui vient boire
une petite infusion à l'eau de pluie qui
coule pourtant du robinet
c'est un portrait de le puits qui a plu
hier par exemple alors il y a de l'eau
de la ville il y a aussi de l'eau qui
est potabilisée et voilà il mélange les
deux et donc on a cette eau-là 20% d'eau
de pluie 20 % de recycler et 60% d'eau
municipales pour être exact
[Rires]
et le goût alors
ça n'a pas un goût particulier ça n'a
pas de boum marqué quoi
je bois toujours de l'eau du robinet ici
il y a pas de loup et c'est vrai que
certains de mes voisins se sont plaintes
du goût de l'eau par moment j'ai jamais
rien remarqué moi non plus et comme tous
les locataires alexandrean expérimente
une gestion de l'eau innovante un test
grandeur nature de cinq ans pour essayer
de diminuer la consommation d'eau des
Français 148 litres par personne et par
jour dans la douche un dispositif
particulier indique le nombre de litres
consommés
au début ça va faire du vert à partir de
10 litres le pommeau va se colorer en
bleu puis à partir de 30 litres en
violet puis à 40 en rouge et là donc
voilà on a plus que 10 litres et jusqu'à
20 litres ça va faire du bleu des
économies d'eau qui vont au-delà des
recommandations de l'ADEME l'Agence de
la transition écologique qui suggère de
ne pas dépasser une douche de 5 minutes
soit en moyenne 50 litres d'eau le but
c'est vraiment par exemple pour moi de
pas dépasser la douche bleue et c'est
pas vraiment pas compliqué quoi et en
été c'est plutôt la verte et je la
dépasse pas seul problème dans cet
appartement Alexandre ne peut pas boire
l'eau de cette toilette
il y en a pas besoin à cet endroit là
d'avoir de l'eau potable justement et ça
du coup c'est l'eau qui vient de notre
douche ou de notre lavabo et après elle
part en bas elle revient et donc dans
nos toilettes on a différents
elle provient du même raccordement que
l'eau des robinets
un énorme gâchis rendez-vous compte 93%
de l'eau que nous utilisons les pour la
lessive l'entretien l'hygiène corporelle
un énorme gâchis évité dans cet immeuble
expérimental construit et gérée par
Grenoble habitat le bailleur social de
la ville tenu par les écologistes
[Musique]
comment tout cela fonctionne-t-il pour
le savoir il faut prendre de la hauteur
c'est sur le toit de ce bâtiment unique
en France que tout commence avec ses
1000 mètres carrés de panneaux solaires
ils assurent non seulement 70%
d'autonomie électrique à l'immeuble mais
ils ont aussi une autre fonction plus
originale
l'architecte Carole Valade et le
directeur technique de la ville sont là
pour tout nous expliquer quand il pleut
l'eau ruisselle sur les panneaux arrive
dans les gouttières qui sont ici et
descendent dans ces tuyaux jusqu'au
local de potabilisation qui est au
rez-de-chaussée vous l'avez compris tout
repose sur un complexe technique situé
en bas nous redescendons
le saint des saints du bâtiment le voici
l'eau collecter en fait sous nos pieds
il y a 150 mètres cubes de stockage
d'eau ça c'est les
[Applaudissements]
autrui donc un filtre à charbon actif
ici pour un premier traitement au niveau
de l'eau et derrière donc un bioréacteur
à membrane qui vient aussi assurer le
second traitement avant le passage en
filtration et traitement
UV et puis après donc on arrive sur la
partie dans laquelle se fait le dernier
équilibrage de la potabilisation avec
des traitements acido-basique un
traitement complexe il s'agit d'éliminer
tout acidité tout micro-organismes
vivants qui pourraient s'y trouver l'eau
de pluie est toujours mélangée avec de
l'eau municipale qui apporte les
minéraux nécessaires pour la rendre
complètement potable ensuite il y a ce
qu'on appelle les eaux grises les eaux
issues des éviers baignoires et autres
machines à laver le linge on recollecte
au niveau
lavabo douche et matériel
électroménagers pour revenir traiter ces
eaux grises et redescervir ça dans les
WC au niveau du jardin pour l'arrosage
l'eau des toilettes elle est directement
évacuée vers les centres
d'assainissement de la ville impossible
de la traiter ici cela nécessite des
installations beaucoup plus grandes
Alexandre est bien heureux en son jardin
elle est un petit peu d'eau assez
betteraves qui elles ont pris un peu la
chaleur il reste encore trois ans
d'expérimentation mais les résultats
sont déjà là en moyenne ici les
habitants consomment 80 litres d'eau par
jour contre 148 pour le reste de la
population le modèle serait transposable
à l'échelle d'un quartier de mille
logements malgré les coûts cet immeuble
très technique nécessite de gros
investissements le bailleur il y a des
pensées 13 millions d'euros mais
l'avenir n'a pas de prix n'est-ce pas
la technologie va-t-elle pouvoir nous
sauver de nous-mêmes à elle seule
sûrement pas on va avoir besoin de la
technologie et ce qui était présenté ici
dans le reportage et tout à fait
innovant et assez remarquable et
évidemment ça permet de mettre en place
des mesures de cebrité la question l'eau
des toilettes effectivement c'est une
aberration mais la réalité c'est que les
gens n'ont pas le choix et ne décident
pas eux-mêmes du système de raccordement
qu'il y a dans leur immeuble et donc
effectivement il faut mettre en place ce
type de solution technologies par contre
la technologie ne peut pas servir
d'alibi pour perpétuer toute une série
de modèles du passé qui vont
littéralement se fracasser sur le mur du
changement climatique et donc tout le
défi que nous avons en tant que société
c'est de voir comment nous allons
pouvoir nous servir de la technologie
tout en repensant certains modèles et
comment la technologie peut aussi nous
aider à repenser et à transformer
certains modèles du passé aujourd'hui la
redevance de l'eau est payée à 90% par
les usagers domestiques alors qu'ils
n'utilisent que 22% de nos produits
l'agriculture en fait trois à quatre
pour cent alors qu'elle en consomme 45%
et on était jusqu'à 80% s équitable non
et c'est mais on pourrait le dire pour
l'eau on peut le dire aussi pour le
kérosène pour toute une série d'usage du
carbone c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui le
gros problème économique c'est ce qu'on
appelle un échec du marché en terme
économique c'est-à-dire que les impacts
environnementaux ne sont pas pris en
compte dans le prix et un gros enjeu
c'est d'internaliser cela dans le prix
de manière à mettre en place un prix
équitable pour tous pour l'eau pour le
carbone et pour d'autres ressources il y
a pas cette question d'équité on aura
des conflits tout la tarification
progressive que vous allez mettre en
place bien sûr de aussi une volonté de
rééquilibrage vous auriez pu citer les
centrales nucléaires on a aujourd'hui on
utilise de l'eau pour de la production
d'énergie justement alors qu'il y a
aujourd'hui une cotisation qui est
quasiment égale à zéro et qu'il faut
évidemment qu'on intègre dans le prix
pour éviter de la malle adaptation et
pour pas partir de n'importe quelle
direction mais plus largement
notre fiscalité nos prix font comme si
nous avions des ressources qui étaient
gratuites et infinies vous parlez des
centrales nucléaires elles sont
effectivement très gourmandes en eau le
refroidissement des réacteurs
capteraient 30% de la ressource alors
qu'on est en plein examen de la loi sur
la construction de nos réacteurs le
nucléaire est-il viable à l'heure de la
raréfaction de l'eau Florence
actuels peuvent se faire du souci il y a
eu souvent des arrêts notamment parce
que la température de l'eau est en trop
chaude il ne pouvait pas rejeter de
l'eau chaude dans le milieu et
effectivement dans je crois dans le
projet il y a eu très peu de centrales
sur des rivières parce que je pense que
on peut s'inquiéter sur les débits
d'étiages qui seront peut-être pas
suffisants alors justement la baisse du
débit de Rhône et de ses affluents
devraient s'accélérer comment continuer
à assurer dans ces conditions et
productions nucléaires et
hydroélectriques alors plus constant
vous avez une étude très intéressante
qui a été faite par la Cour des comptes
à la demande du Sénat dans le cas
d'effectivement de la l'évolution de la
politique énergétique et qui liste la
des recommandations qui sont probables
on a potentiellement des technologies de
circuits fermés au lieu d'être en
prélèvement mais qui pose d'autres
difficultés parce que vous allez
retrouver à moins prélevé mais à plus
consommer absolument on a globalement
des solutions qui sont technologiques en
reprenant exactement l'angle de François
Germaine ne pas imaginer que la
technologie va nous permettre de tout
régler mais avoir l'humidité de mesurer
que ça n'est pas que on transforme en
comportements qu'on sera aussi capable
de faire face à une partie des défis qui
sont en face de nous moi ce que je
souhaiterais
dire par rapport à ça c'est que jusqu'à
maintenant la logique c'est le principe
de précaution pourquoi l'eau potable
pourquoi l'eau est potable dans le fond
des toilettes parce que jusqu'à
maintenant la vision du ministère de la
santé c'est que si un enfant buvait
l'eau des toilettes on pourrait se
retrouver avec un risque si l'eau
n'était pas potable de procès sur le
fait que ça a généré quelque chose 20%
de fuite en moyenne sur nos réseaux
d'eau potable 20% de fuite un litre
d'eau sur 5 qui est produit
ça montre l'ampleur de ce qu'on a à
conduire parce que ce sont des moyennes
et que vous avez des endroits on l'a vu
malheureusement on atteint 70% de fuite
on a 2000 communes qui se sont retrouvés
en fragilité avec des risques de perte
de potable ça a concerné plutôt des
petits villages mais on n'est pas à
l'abri que des agglomérations de taille
plus importante se retrouvent devant des
difficultés de ce type le maître mot
sera la sobriété on ne leur arrivera
jamais assez regardé le passé est clair
l'avenir Charlotte et PAL est donc
allait fouillée dans les archives de
Lina et elle nous a exhumé ceci hier
encore c'est notre coup d'oeil dans le
rétro et c'est maintenant
un bruit bien sympathique quand il fait
29 degrés à l'ombre un bruit d'eau bien
entendu un bruit d'eau dans un nouveau
puits au sud de la Seine-et-Marne
monsieur joignot vous êtes cultivateur
je crois oui
par cette sécheresse et bien écoutez il
est certain que les nos récoltes ont
souffert de la sécheresse mais par
exemple moi producteur de maïs on n'y
Palli quand même avec l'arrosage je fais
de l'irrigation j'ai un puits privé de
ce puits j'arrose donc vous avez de
l'eau là pour mes récoltes pour mes maïs
oui
m'excuse de vous interrompre monsieur de
ramez vous êtes vétérinaire vous êtes en
même temps conseillé général du
département qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
donner comme conseil à noter les
spectateurs c'est qu'il faut absolument
aujourd'hui ne pas qu'ils aient une
psychose de manque d'eau et que tous les
soirs sous prétexte que on a entendu
dire que on a les manquer d'eau on a les
ceci on remplit les baignoires on
remplit toutes les citernes on remplit
on remplit des bouteilles
on l'utilise pas parce que on la vide le
lendemain matin dans le ruisseau dans
les égouts et puis le lendemain matin
quand on voit de lourd commence à
recouler au robinet on recommence à
remplir pour la deuxième fois vous êtes
maire de Villemer mais oui monsieur
Jacques voulez-vous me parler un peu du
problème de l'eau chez vous bien le
problème de l'eau chez nous ayez-vous
nous sommes fournisseurs d'eau ah ben
alors vous me manquez de rien voilà nous
sommes fournisseurs d'eau à la ville de
Paris qui a capté notre source en 1900
nous laissant tout est pour tout 200
mètres cubes par jour en 1900 c'était
largement suffisant parce que tout le
monde avait son puits maintenant on a
tout de même laduction d'eau comme dans
beaucoup de communes mais les 200 mètres
cubes ne suffisent plus et en ce moment
par la sécheresse qui fait et bien le
soir dans le petit amendement brille où
nous sommes en ce moment il y a plus
d'eau François German et j'aimerais
terminer là-dessus vous rappeler très
justement de votre livre qu'il est
possible pour une entreprise de se
transformer radicalement Nokia fabriquer
des bottes en caoutchouc avant de
fabriquer des téléphones et des
composants électroniques Nintendo
vendaient des cartes à jouer avant de
vendre des consoles de jeux American
Express le saviez-vous Christophe Béchu
était un réseau de diligence avant de se
lancer dans des cartes de crédit et
surtout shell vendeur des antiquités et
des coquillages avant de devenir un
géant d'être libre rien n'est perdu à
qui a envie de se réinventer ces
entreprises n'existeraient sans doute
plus si elle n'avait pas changé leur
mode absolument il y a plus qu'à je vous
donne rendez-vous le mois prochain merci
à tous les trois d'ici là serrons-nous
les coups des bon courage que ce véhu il
y a du boulot merci à vous il y a du
boulot pour tout le monde parce qu'il
faut que ce soit toute la société qui
bouge et pas seulement ce qui savent ou
ceux qui prennent des décisions il y a
un enjeu pour embarquer tout le monde
dans cette transition on y va
[Musique]